I don't think we think enough about what
we're eating I have a lot of belief in
eating food lives I know that that is
the best food for me to grab hold to
because I know that every time I'm
cooking something to certain
temperatures I'm killing the life in
that food
let food be thy medicine and Medicine be
thy food so I would explain to people
I put a salad on your plate so you have
some life on your plate that is why we
have the menu that we have tacos
burritos quesadillas you know what I'm
saying it's a it's one of those soul
food I make sweet potato pie I just
don't use a dozen eggs in it like my
mama did you don't have to really omit
anything
but death that's the only thing I'm
asking you to stop ingesting